it happens and most likely you are
storing things in the brain and you're
confusing for me your fantasy with the
reality and were you one possibility the
other possibility like he had the wrong
perception of what you saw so you store
in a certain way because you're
convinced that that it's that way but it
was not that way if let's say
a stupid example I mean you're convinced
that maybe were not did not pay that
much attention and you convince the
person was dressed in red instead it was
pink or a color close to read then then
you you store the thing in that that way
obviously with time and the memory will
become more far away certain aspect
could disappear and we could fill them
with other aspect just to fill the gap
so we make up for the memory and we
build up the memory and the time of
recalling the memory we are recalling
stuff that occurred in other
circumstances because I mean it's a
memory it's not our brain is not there a
recorder like passive recorder it's a
more active process so being an active
process there are could be ways of you
know changing it because actively we can
we can change it so that's something
which is important it's not that word
brain is like a tape recorder or a TV or
vcr I mean it's not the lattice it was
more active than that and there are
several steps in the process of memory
and recalling a memory which there are
many many steps several steps and each
one of them as memory could be labelled
and could be you know changed doing for
something else which you do by something
else
visitor you have to look at member as a
process in which there are several steps
which they imply some I say some
interference from it's not the right
word processing of our brain of this
information and this it's just purely
active and it has changed it's like when
you change something from analog to
digital just to make one of those things
not the video from the computer and in
that process of changing from analog to
digital you can change something and
will not be the same you know what if
you change the cheap or something and
you change the yellow into a green so
what there was yellow will be green and
or a when I say nay you can even have to
fish alee change it to into a B if you
want because if you tell the computer to
change all the a into a beat and
everything would be a baby or sometimes
you this process some may will changing
their be then will change there is some
activity something that is they are
occurring and it changes